let me help you remember the first thing
you're gonna do is able to take this
negative 7 right I don't really want the
expo people so I'm going to add 7 to
both sides that leads me miss so
obviously that's probably what your
first night we did my it's a helpful way
now the next one is to complete the
square as the name suggests so is
another I can add select inside which
when I factorize it for me to swear so I
get that number by Polly is very you
have an au squared Harvey that gives you
do u 2 square is so I get plus 4 plus 4
because of course equations we should
say about this I've got 11 of the right
hand side that's no big deal but on the
left hand side would like it I've
created a squares X minus 2 all squared
okay so for that now you're probably
familiar Judy I'm going to have also
minus the square root of lemon on the
right hand side and in the last thing
left is to add to both sides so this
should be so we've got two solutions
comes up if I test in the mouth I should
be able to find the left hand side
movies Europe in leadership now all
we're going to look at right now is how
do we use that because this skill what
we do is because quiet to a particular
situation in Matthew Lee this was
applications like not like I submitted
an application for a job or you know
apply the skill to a particular kind of
problem so we'll give these will give
this for quite some time
the problem yesterday was if you
remember we wanted to find the vertex of
this shape and then we could draw
remember that everything about what was
the way we did that we found a
particular line that helped us get the
vertex what was the one once you find
that which by the way what is the axis
of symmetry you would unity formula x
equals so you evaluate that or maybe you
look is whether two x-intercepts are
eager halfway I diversify once you find
that you can get the vertex can you put
that x value into this equation if you
get a Y value and you're done
but completely the square gives us
another way to find out where the vertex
is without going through this awkward
way okay
so how will we use complete the square
this method to find the vertex of this
well one of these think about the
quadratic climate that can become a
square now if I have this s square plus
eight is on the left hand side you I
know what to do to get the next number I
would take eight than I would on some
are that's where you have to choose call
this way gives you 16 okay now this is a
bit weird slightly different just very
much like between the switch good
attendees but I already have a ballast
down on left to right I can have like a
0 on the right hand side so in order to
make sure I haven't actually changed
this equation and the same time is
adding 16 I'm going to take away these
name that looks strange I think
something
adding something to take it away but
what I'm trying to do is make that
square nicely that's why this is here
but I'm trying to make sure it doesn't
change what is real original problem so
that's 5 plus 16 minus 16
it's still the same watch so what I've
now created in this little sentence here
this is a sweat right just like over
here what is a swim very good
X plus 4 now we can collect some like
terms only this is gonna be by this so I
would do one more thing to this and
we're going to use this method so this
form here you can put a box around them
this is another form of writing the
parabola see this one is general form
you've seen that before
that's what you usually get but this is
called vertex form because you know how
to read it it literally just tells you
what the vertex is okay if you recall
what y equals x squared looks like we're
very familiar with this shape it just
looks like that okay so this is mushy
our regular parabola okay it's sensitive
or its vertex brother is at the origin
thank you oops I want you to tell me
what that would look like in comparison
what would it look like it's moved
somewhere it's just like that is moved
somewhere have you basically move two
units okay so we know it's move to get
okay but who's going to give you is it
so my axis which what is up Democrats
right the y-axis is them up and down the
x-axis is left and right
origin zero x equals zero that's okay
this is it's a bit strange because I see
that - we usually think of as a negative
but you're going to the right and make
it look this plus that's a positive but
it actually gives you to the left so
we've got forty minutes unless that was
what the exes some people wise as well
right
no crisis we guess you can't buy new
boobs you've got help up when eleven
units that's how far you've gone but
which way tomorrow and wise are about up
and down right where's your about
popping outside no he's buy them up or
down but do you see how this is we
backwards people buy this to you would
become as a number to the left right but
it's moved you to the right plus four
you would think of as another to the
right but it's Mooji to the left so
everything is reversed which is a little
strange so the leather units but calm
down
so from that information I have about
the person the vertex person 1000
anymore the vertex well if you start
from 0 0 and here is 4 units to the left
you're going to be at negative 4 that
would be your x coordinate and what we
work would it be you've got this okay so
let me just rewind a second you start
with a problem so I called an equation
you do this complete the square business
and if you get into this this phone here
you can read off the vertex its these
opposite numbers maybe before